acidulée douron de toutes les couleurs
plus de 150 confiserie différentes
s'offrent à la vue et parfois au palais
des visiteurs voici la niche de quiberon
donc celle ci est au beurre salé caramel
beurre salé et dont le parfum est très
développée très sucré on sent tout tous
les produits naturels
bon oui certains portent des noms pour
le moins étonnants comme ses pâtes
d'amande chocolat framboise et armagnac
les coucougnettes du vert-galant inventé
en 98 à pau clin d'oeil à la pythie
amoureux et sexuels dans l'es4 et de nom
veut dire soute et cajoler d'où la
présentation et la forme du ballon mais
les bonbons en france c'est d'abord une
histoire de régions dans le sud est de
la france on a plus des bonbons à base
de fruits confits à base de sucre les
bonbons dapd en remontant près sur l'est
de la france on a plus et bonbons à base
de bourgeons de miel à base de sapins à
base et des pattes de gomme pour soigner
davantage prêts dans le nord de la
france on a plus des bonbons en base de
sucre 2 comme l'a pas si du mineur comme
les barbus ville de lille et puis après
le sud est de la france on va comprendre
plus les bonbons en base de pâte
d'amandes de noisettes
tout le monde sait qu annie aime les
sucettes à l'anis et doux pour la gorge
et pour tous ses bienfaits il faut
remercier les égyptiens les bonbons sont
arrivés il ya 600 ans avant notre ère
par là l'egypte par les pharaons par le
miel et ensuite c'est arrivé par la
gaule romaine puis après progressivement
ciblé par catherine de médicis au xvième
siècle qu'il instaurait à sa cour en
revenant d'italie le tour de france des
bonbons c'est jusqu'au 6 juin
profitez-en vous aurez ensuite tout le
temps de voir votre dentiste